it's a pretentious music critic time
let's go
hold up can i guess these
please guess them this is okay i know
this one
this is from that one video where it was
like this is your rapper's favorite
rapper
doctor doom
it's mf
i know that unfortunately he passed away
not too long ago as well right yeah yeah
he died
actually i recognize radiohead yep
that's that's radiohead yeah is that who
they are yeah is he going on a tv show
you look i feel like i've seen him on tv
tom york being on a tv show i don't know
can we
google that am i going crazy maybe i
don't know
please
i'll be surprised if you can get anyone
else
i know one of them
is this drake bell
yeah i know one of them's tool yeah
that's tall yes yeah
why do they all look the same
is this
a british man yes
it could be like the who or the sex
pistols or it could be one of them it's
not who or sex crystals but it's that
era yeah i feel like they all look good
okay i'm british they all look exactly
the same
okay so from left to right we've got
tool led zeppelin okay radiohead screen
pink floyd nick drake mf doom american
football and maida jun my brother's
going to [ __ ] kill me he absolutely
is obsessed with like led zeppelin
really yeah he was obsessed with that he
loves all of those that are abandoned oh
yes
i mean i could have put like nine just
70s hard rock bands as well if i wanted
to because i i love a lot of their music
but a lot at the same time i have no
idea what any of the bands look like
like black sabbath i know what ozzy
osbourne looks like now yeah i don't
know what he looked like
he got he looked so different back there
yeah
ozzy osbourne actually looked like a
human yeah
uh aged strangely
yeah when i saw him live it was uh it
was weird aussie is like you know those
those time lapses of like this chicken
nugget has been in the closet for 70
years and hasn't aged but it has and
it's that's how i feel i don't know why
is that a fair comparison
that's how i feel it's like it shouldn't
be alive but it looks
worryingly well yeah it's like aussie
now kind of looks like if someone took
ozzy osbourne deflated him and then
re-inflated him again
like it looks like someone took audrey
osbourne and just like he left him in
water for too long
like an insane amount of drugs or
something oh yeah yeah i mean i mean
most he should have died ages ago
normally but uh he's some i mean that's
why he can barely talk now like when i
went to go see black sabbath live it was
like the the like you know the the
original line price is still performing
yeah i mean this was like maybe five six
years ago and it was labeled their last
tour right so i was like oh of course i
have to go that's impressive that he's
still able to perform yeah well that's
the thing it's like he came like from
like when they all came onto stage and
like the music starts playing and you
just see this guy just like hobbling
across the stage right and i'm like oh
that's him there he is and he just goes
up to the mic and he's like
normal
can you not
why can you sing this is completely fine
but you can't talk
you haven't lived in the uk test i can
understand him like perfectly
i'm not i'm not even joking
i could understand what he was i don't
know what it is man yeah the uk is weird
it doesn't matter it gives you like uh
like it's it's like the hard mode of
english
like once once you're trained in it then
you could he you could like distinguish
any access no difficulties understanding
english access yeah because i just grew
up around really strange ones but i
guess like black sabbath like so led
zeppelin for me is like kind of just
all of like the british like 70s like
hard rock man black sabbath can fit in
there like deep purple can fit in there
because like that's just like the music
my dad just grew up with and he was like
here
do you know rolling stones and i was
like and i was two years old and i was
like what is the music and then he just
played rolling stones and i was like
okay i can get behind this and then i
think the first band i like really
connected to was led zeppelin yeah um
yeah like i [ __ ]
love it
i'm okay i'm gonna i'm not like an idiot
they're gonna do stairway to her yes
they are the ones who do something
wrong stairway to heaven rock and roll
black dog uh
immigrant song immigrant song um
[Music]
often living in japan you'll meet like
let's say you're just me talking to
japanese people whatever and they'll be
like oh i love i love british music oh
okay i'm thinking like [ __ ] watch which
ear are they going to talk to me because
i don't know any of them yeah there's
always like black sabbath let's settle
in and they'll be like they'll ask me
what's your favorite song i'll be like
[Applause]
this is where like my [ __ ] levels
come into like how well can i do this
yeah yeah this is a really but basically
uh like
jimmy page who's the guitarist for led
zeppelin he's the one who basically
influenced me to start guitar right yeah
so like i watched one concert from led
zeppelin and i was like that is the
coolest [ __ ] human alive like just
like him just shredding on guitar i was
like i want what he has i want that can
i do that is it a coincidence they're
all posing very similarly and
like they just happen to all have the
same looking posts i just yeah i mean
that's just like
we are a bear we are a band we're doing
pretty well yeah we are a band um
um yeah so i guess like yeah so led
zeppelin's just like like just my love
for like 70s rock so like black sabbath
deep purple rolling stones it's been
really hard for you to decide it's
really hard because your your music
knowledge is vast yeah yeah and i feel
like you have an appreciation for music
yeah way beyond anything meaning yeah
like me and connors like a music puddle
yours is like a music ocean you know
basically um and then i guess like kind
of in the same vein but i had to like
put it sim uh differently as pink floyd
in the middle yeah
yeah yeah like i think i went to a
concert of pink floyd's well technically
just roger waters um and he and he
performed that pink flight has this
album called the wall yeah which is like
considered like one of the greatest like
concept albums joey has explained the
wall to me in great deepest yeah i like
how you said they made this album called
the wall but like it's not like one of
the most favorite because because people
always think like oh yeah they made dark
side of the moon it's like that's the
one i knew oh is that the one that
nostalgia critic made right right
yeah yeah my favorite
princess i love that i love that apple
amazing amazing i love nostalgia critic
but um so he so roger waters was the guy
who like mostly wrote the wall but like
the entire band like did it as well but
like he went on like a tour all around
the world to perform the wall
um and so i got tickets to it like
miraculously from a friend of mine and i
was like oh my god my dreams gonna
[ __ ] come true like i get to see one
of my favorite bands but like it wasn't
a concert it was a [ __ ] stage show
right so like again the whole concept of
the wall is like guy creates a wall
that's like not physical and then he
like breaks it down like get over his
musical and uh emotional barriers right
super over simplifying the album okay
thank you that's what i mean speed run
but what's amazing what was amazing
about that concert is that as they are
playing the songs throughout the album
they're literally physically building a
wall on stage
with like it like not obviously not made
out of bricks
like like like big like styrofoam so
like after every song
the band members actually like go off
the stage and like place bricks on the
wall that's cool and then in the in the
second half and then in the first half
of the album he finishes building the
wall and then it just goes into like
uh an interesting funded by donald trump
yeah definitely he was like i want it
taller
and then and then the second half
the the wall is built right but they
build it in front of the band so as the
concert is going on you can see less and
less
that's so cool and then the second half
of the album starts the entire
stage spins around
that's how we're looking and so now
you're looking from inside the wall
and then because that's the theme of the
second half of the album and then at one
point and at the end the stage round it
was it was all just on this like giant
like lazy susan-esque like just rotating
the thing right um and then
like second the second-to-last song on
the album the main protagonist of the
album he breaks down the wall and they
literally like blow this [ __ ] up
and just the pieces just go flying into
the crowd and then the album just stands
and like i've never like
cried during a concert but that was the
first time i was like
like it was one of those concerts where
it's like you know normally like say if
you go see muse or like pendulum right
yeah you're [ __ ] like standing up
you're like grooving you're singing
along you're like [ __ ] yeah you know
like that kind of thing that was the
first ever concert i went to where i was
just like
my ass firmly planted on the seat and
just staring right and just like
listening and like taking it in because
it's like i wish i could have that
because
it was it was crazy it was like one of
the like i've been a lot of concerts in
my life but that was like one of the
most like
like ethereal is like the only way i can
describe it it's just so like oh my god
as someone who doesn't understand a lot
of like the deeper appeal of music like
what it what makes the wall such an
amazing album because like to me the
wall is just like the album you say if
you want to impress a dad
you know like like
you you me you me you mean your
girlfriend's dad or something and you're
like crazy do you like yeah
i like the walls i love pink floyd's the
wall and yeah like
easy [ __ ] brownie points yeah of
course of course i love ipas i
um i guess so i did like a whole
dissertation on the wall i did like a
fork so i took like music as like a
major in high school because i wanted to
like pursue it at uni obviously i didn't
end up pursuing anything your dads were
like no no you're asian joey yeah yeah
you got to do it
right now
and uh like one of like i did i studied
like musicology which is just like music
analysis basically yeah and they were
like and like the year-long dissertation
was take an album and just like write a
dissertation about like write an album
like write an album review basically i
wrote like this like 40 page like
dissertation on the wall and like what's
like the most insane thing about the
wall is like not just the fact that like
the story is cohesive and like
all the songs flow together like there
is no pauses between any of the songs as
it flows from one song to another like
the entire album is connected to just
one big song but the most amazing like
mind-blowing thing is the fact that the
album literally repeats and that's cool
right right so the end the ending of the
last song fades into the beginning of
the first song that's really cool and
like that just like completely like and
and that's not just like a stylistic
thing like they did that on purpose to
show that like what this main character
is going through
is a never-ending cycle right right and
it's just it's just constantly repeating
over and over again did that as well
with uh
with the eagle right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so like uh the wall was i'd say it
was like the first album to like
incorporate that style and like a lot of
obviously like tyler and like a lot of
artists took that yeah um but yeah i
mean like you know i've always said that
like you can make like a concept heavy
album right and like try and tell a
story but if the music sucks then the
music's gonna stop
no one likes this song right it's like
you could you could have the most like
deep ass like message about like you
know whatever the [ __ ] you're trying to
sing about but if the song doesn't stick
with you then it's like there's no point
yeah
the wall though is like every song's a
[ __ ] banger so even if you listen to
it individually it's like oh it's a
great [ __ ] song it's still [ __ ]
slaps and then on top of that it's like
oh it's deep as well and profound and
it's lyrics it's like
what more could you ask for all right
um
you know and like what the one thing
though that annoys the [ __ ] out of me is
the fact that another brick in the wall
is from this album and it's like pink
floyd's most well-known song yeah right
just because and like it's a bob but so
many people just listen to it out of
context so they don't know what it means
because they don't know what it means
because like if you're actually in the
yeah because in the context of the album
it's a really [ __ ] depressing song
yeah right but it's just like played in
an upbeat and it's like it's like a
great song right like i'm not gonna
fault them for that but um yeah i don't
know and like all their albums just like
that they've never had a bad album it
might be